ضحايا زلزال سوريا وتركيا ما بنبالغ لو
قلنا انهم بالملايين فغير القتلى والجرحى
بنقدر نقول بكل واقعيه انه في ازمه نفسيه
جماعيه سببها الزلزال في الاف النجين اللي
لحظات الزلزال اثرت في نفسياتهم هدول اللي
نجوا في لحظتها تخيلوا عادي اللي قعدوا
ساعات او ايام تحت الانقاض قديش حجم الضغط
النفسي اللي تعرضوا له في كمان الازمه
النفسيه اللي بيعانيها الناس اللي الان
خسروا اهل وقرايب وجيران واصحاب في هذا
الزلزال المدمر وفي كمان فرق الانقاذ
واللي شافوه وعايشوه والازمه اللي ممكن
يعانوا منها الان ومع فارق حجم الماساه
طبعا لكن غير كل هدول في الناس اللي في
دول ثانيه وبعيده وجسد بتتابع الاخبار
المؤلمه والمؤثره هذه وهذول كمان تاثرت
نفسياتهم بما حدث يعني صراحه من فداحه
الحدث يعني خلينا نحكي عن هذا الموضوع مع
صديقنا الطبيب النفسي دكتور ليث العبادي
اهلا فيك معنا دكتور ليث يعني ناس تتكلم
عن انه تروما جماعيه او صدمه جماعيه هل
نقدر فعلا نقول انه في شيء مشترك صدمه
مشتركه ممكن تجمع كل الناس اللي عاصروا
هذا الحدث
على الاستضافه وهو حدث حزين
والصدمه على جميع حتى اللي بيشاهدوا في
التلفاز واحنا عن بعد مصابين بصدمه بشبهوا
قوه الزلزال
بقنابل ذريه وانا بشبهه بمجموعه قنابل
نفسيه انفجرت في كل العالم
اللي ذكرتيها الان عن انواع مختلفه من
انواع الصدمات هاي كلها اجت مع بعضها يعني
الصدمه الجسديه والاذى الجسدي اللي اصاب
المصابي غير عن فقدان اشخاص اخرين غير عن
فقدان المنزل غير عن تغيير في في كل
الامور غير عن الطقس والبرد يعني مجموعه
ضغوطات نفسيه كبيره بمر عليها فيها العالم
كله بدرجات متفاوته اكثر ناس طبعا اللي هم
اللي تاثروا بشكل مباشر في هذا الزلزال هل
في اسم نفسي للصدمه الجماعيه مثلا هذه
اللي بيعيشوها
او العلميه يعني
كوارث طبيعيه والاضطرابات النفسيه ما بعد
الفوارث الطبيعيه وهي نفس الاشياء اللي
بتيجي للناس مثلا بعد الحروب
ما بعد الصدمه وهو تقريبا شيء مشابه بمر
للشخص بحاله مختلطه من الحزن والقلق
والتوتر واليقظه كانه لحظه الصدمه تستمر
معه وتعود له على شكل ذكريات بعد المرور
بوقت صعب جدا الذكريات فجاه بتيجي مباشر
مباغته بدون انت ما تختار فيها اي خيار
والله يعين كل من هو مصاب فيها الخيالات
من ذكريات تعاد نفس لحظه وقوع الحادث
مرارا وتكرارا وبالعاده يحاول الشخص انه
يخفف عن نفسه بالتجنب ولكن اللي واقع تحت
المشكله والمصيبه سيكون صعب عليه تجنب وقد
يكون عامل مساعد يعني ان شاء الله طيب
دكتور ليث لما نيجي نحن بنت في هذا
الموضوع الان ويعني فعليا انت ذكرت يعني
خساره حياه خساره منزل خساره تفاصيل كثيره
يعني الواحد يعجز عن وصفه يعني هل هذا
الموضوع لما نتكلم عنه الان في وسط ما
الامور هذه جالسه بتصير رفاهيه يمكن لازم
ناجلها لبعدين
امل النفسي مهم جدا جدا جدا حتى على
العامل الجسدي يعني
العلاج في جزء من الحزن والانكار يعني في
ناس صابوا خدش من الانهيار من المصابين
يجب ان يتلقى الرعايه والدعم الطبي النفسي
باسرع وقت في بعض الناس اذا دخل في نوبه
كلياتنا ساره تحت الضغط نستجيب بشكل مختلف
في البعض بيحزن شوي بتوتر شوي ولكن في
البعض ممكن يدخل بنوبات من اضطرابات نفسيه
شديده اذا تركت ان تعالج بعدين ممكن تخلف
اثر لا نستطيع علاجه بالاضطرابات النفسيه
بشكل عام كلما طالت مده النوبه انما صعد
وصعب علاج اوكي فانت بتقول انه لا بد من
الان انه التعامل مع هذا الموضوع واضافه
العلاج النفسي كما العلاج الجسدي يعني
ومعالجين ومسعفين النفسيين بنفس اهميه وقد
يكون اهم في بعض الحالات حذف شده الحاله
دكتور ليث يمكن واحده من الاشياء طبعا
يعني البارقه العمل اللي شفناها في هذه
الازمه خروج ناس احياء من تحت الانقاب في
مجناس احياء من تحت الانقاض في منهم حتى
اطفال في منهم رضع الاطفال تحديدا والرضع
هدول لاي درجه حيتذكروا تحديدا هذا اللي
صار وقديش ممكن يكون يؤثر على مستقبلهم
يؤثر بسبب التغيير اللي خلفه بغض النظر عن
العمر ولكن الذكرى كذكره وصدمه ما يعني
بتكون اقل في الاعمار ما اقل من ست سنوات
بقفل 6 سنوات بتكون امور اوضح ولكن التغير
المفاجئ اللي ممكن يصير في نظام الحياه
الاطفال متعودين على الروتين معين والنظام
وجدول ثابت من الساعات استيقاظ ساعات نوم
اشكال وجوه ناس هاي الاشياء تغيرها وفقدان
الاهل ومقدمين رعايه في عمر حتى سنتين الى
ثلاث سنوات بشكل دور كبير على تشكيل
شخصيته في المستقبل فالاطفال الرضع حتى
وبس بشكل اكبر من بعد السنه لعمر ثلاث
سنوات حتى فيها بالعمر قد يؤثر عليهم سلبا
بشكل كبير اذا ما تم تعويضهم يعني رح يكون
صعب التعويض بشكل كامل ولكن قدر الامكان
العوده الى نظام الحياه السابق على الاقل
من ساعات نوم ساعات
استيقاظ ووجبات اكل ورعايه ودفع كمان
دكتور الليث يعني يمكن كمان الان لانه
وسائل الاعلام كلها تطورت وصارت الناس
بتقابلهم اول ما بيطلعوا بياخدوا منهم
حوارات وفيديوهات هدول الاطفال لاحقا يعني
عندهم حتى فيديوهات بتوثق هذه اللحظه
المريعه اللي عاشوها قديش تعتقد انه
يعني مش صحي للاطفال مقابلتهم في هذا
الوقت ولا يعني كيف نقدر نسميه يعني في
نهايه اليوم شغله الصحفي اكيد انه يلتقط
الخبر والحدث في هذه اللحظه وفي هذه
اللحظه يوثق حدث انه في شخص طلع عايش من
تحت الانقاض واكيد لكن ماذا عن هذا الشخص
ندور الاعلام الايجابي بتسليط الضوء على
مصائب الاخرين ودفع الناس انها تتبرع
وتساعد وتقوم بفعل عن جد ممكن يفرق ولكن
بنفس الوقت يجب ان يكون حذرين بالاثر
النفسي على المشاهدين وعلى الاشخاص نفسهم
مستقبلا توثيق لحظات معينه والام معينه
يسبب اضطرابات نفسيه في المشاهدين يعني
جزء كبير من مراجعين في العياده في بعض
اللقطات ادت الى بعض الانتكاسات وبعض انت
سوء الحاله النفسيه احنا لابد من شحن
زلزال والام الناس
تحديد الطفل اللي كان يبحث عن كذا يعني في
قصص معينه بحد ذاتها اثرت سلبا نفسيا هسه
انك تجذب التعاطف الجمعي شيء له فوائد
ولكن عند بعض الحالات قد يسبب ويؤدي الى
اثر سلبي جدا وبرضو حتى توثيق الكثير من
اللحظات اللي فيها خصوصيه والتي قد نتعدى
يعني في اعتقد اكيد في كود اخلاقي او او
مرجع اخلاقي للصحفيين بشكل عام يعني بنصح
كل يا اخواننا الصحفيين
في هذه اللحظه والحقيقه يعني كل زملائنا
اللي على الارض يعني هم بيتعاملوا مع
الحدث مش بس كصحفيين هم في النهايه ابي
اتعاملوا معاه كانسان ويعني واضح جدا
تاثرهم في هذيك اللحظات وسعادتهم بانه
مثلا شخص نجا في هذا الموقف وهذا الشيء
وكل التحيه صراحه لكل الطواقم الاعلاميه
اللي جالسه بتغطي وبتنقل يعني الحقيقه بس
خليني ارجع ايضا لموضوع الموضوع
تحديدا يعني للاسف شفنا اسر بكاملها راحت
ومثلا بقي شخص او طفل او ما الى ذلك حتى
في انتشرت صوره لشخص بيقول انه توفت كل
اسرته فكان بيقول كلهم بخير الا انا هل
فعلا ممكن الشخص يشعر
بانه بالذنب او الندم ان هو بيجي عايش
صدمه بشكل عام بتمر اشهرها واشهر تصنيف
اللي هو الانكار الغضب المساومه الاكتئاب
قبل للوصول للقبول وكل هالمراحل وخصوصا
الحزن يرتبط كثيرا بشعور الندم والشعور
بالذنب الخارج عن الفعل اللي قام فيه
الشخص بشكل عام نحن نشعر في الذنب عندما
نقوم بسلوك يتخالف او يختلف مع معتقداتنا
الداخليه الاساسيه ولكن بعد الصدمه شعور
الاكتئاب والحزن الشديد قد يؤدي انه انا
قصرت ماذا لو ماذا لو انا غيرت بصير يبني
تصرفاته ويحاسب نفسه
[موسيقى]
انا ما كنت موجود او كذا او ايش سبب نجاتي
انا تحديدا
وبصير يحاسب نفسه على بعض السلوكيات كانه
يعلم بحدوث الزلزال ولكن ب
ذكر انت لم تكن تعلم بحدوث الزلزال ما قبل
فما كان في شيء كنت ستغيره لانك لا تعلم
الكثير بحكي لو اني غيرت لو اني اخدت ابني
لو اني طلعته كل شخص نجا باللحظات
الكارثيه السريعه كل شخص الوعي يخف ويصير
اذا رده فعل للنجاه بصير في جزء اماكن
اخرى في الدماغ تعمل لكي تنجو بنفسك فحتى
القدره على الحكم ما بتكون بالوضع الحالي
يعني الانسان بيتصرف كده خلاص بغريزته
يعني ما بيفكر في هذيك اللحظه يعني
طيب صراحه موضوع يعني ثقيل عن النفس صراحه
بس كان مهم انه نفتحه معك
وحضرتك كمان قلت انه يعني كثير من
المراجعينك برضو ذكروا هذا الموضوع لما
نراجعوك تاثير موضوع الزلزال واحنا طبعا
هنا في غرفه الاخبار ما عندنا حديث برضو
الا مدى فداحه هذا الموضوع والموضوع عالمي
يعني الكل متاثر طبعا والاخص طبعا اللي
عايشين في وسط الحدث الله يعينهم نحن
بنشكرك على هذه المداخله كان معنا صديقنا
الطبيب النفسي دكتور ليث العبادي شكرا لك